each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
today we have met Welsh from from
Harvard a little bit of our map Matt
actually did his PhD with David color
and also I think i worked with eric
brewer and berkeley what kind of
internet scale services and for other
people in that the community probably
heard of formats work more recently met
has been focusing on sensor network in
particular working on figuring out how
to program these small devices embedded
devices and match talk today is a
market-based resource management for
sensor net so is that great thank you
very much so first of all for those of
you in the room some of you I'm sure
most of you know about sensor networks
already some of you it may not so I'll
have a little bit of introduction what I
want to say is that the work that I've
been doing here has been in
collaboration with my grad student Jeff
mainland and another professor at
Harvard named David parks who's in the
area of applying ideas from economics to
computer science problems so he's done a
lot of very interesting work on you know
auction models and game theory and
things like that so when David and I got
together we started asking the question
how could we use these ideas from
economics to solve problems in the
sensor network space so this is kind of
where things got started so i'm sure
most people here know what sensor
networks are about but in case you don't
the basic idea is to have very very
small very very resource constrained
devices that have a little bit of
computation very low bandwidth very
low-power radio modest amount of memory
and to have just a bunch of them
scattered in the environment to do
various kinds of sensing computation
distributed signal correlation things
like that there's been a lot of
interesting applications for these I'll
talk more about it but the most
important thing from the purpose of this
talk is the fact that they have very
limited resources and so managing the
resources on sensor networks is a very
important problem I think if we're going
to achieve long lifetime and good data
fidelity coming out of them because they
have limited radio bandwidth so
if I had 10,000 sensors sharing two
hundred kilobits of radio bandwidth you
have to be very careful about how you
manage that so this is the the basic
problem that we're trying to solve so
let me give you the canonical
application which a lot of people have
been working on especially my colleagues
at UC Berkeley and other universities on
using sensor networks to track vehicles
and I'll just use this as an example to
motivate the problem so you've got a
field you've scattered some sensor nodes
out in the field you've got a base
station there and what you want to do is
track the location of some vehicle
that's traveling through the network and
in this case preferably a large metallic
object because we're using magnetometer
sensors to detect perturbations in
magnetic field and that will tell you
something about the position of the
vehicle okay and this is a the whole
DARPA nest project is doing this stuff
okay so I'm not making this up people
are actually doing this I've videos of
this stuff working if you don't believe
me but and Alec you know Alec yours in
these videos it's pretty interesting so
you've got a sensor network you've got
enemy vehicle you want to determine the
location of the vehicle and so what
happens is that the sensors near it will
detect some change in the magnetic field
and they will then transmit information
over there radioed back to the base
station to indicate their sensor
readings and in this case the nodes will
transmit something about their sensor
readings and because we have limited
radio bandwidth it's often desirable to
perform some aggregation of the data in
the network so if I have too many sensor
readings to transmit I may need to
combine those results together into a
single sensor reading that i propagate
on because I don't have enough radio
bandwidth to send all the data back to
the base station so there's some
distributed computation some signal
processing some aggregation some
communication going on in the network so
it's a fairly sophisticated program it's
not not all that simple as it turns out
so the problem that our group is working
on is this this issue of how do we
manage the resources in the network so
that we get long lifetime and good use
of the radiant limited radio bandwidth
so if you just think about it for a
minute the action that every
performs the sequence of actions that
every node performs in the network has a
really deep impact on a few things for
one thing it has an impact on the
accuracy of the data that comes out of
the network because the more you sample
the more you communicate the better your
data is but if you don't have enough
energy or radio bandwidth you can't do
it continuously obviously if I transmit
and sample more data than of course I'm
using more radio bandwidth so I might
introduce more radio contention and
collisions and and and cause data to
actually be lost if I try to send too
much and of course battery lifetime so
the battery lifetime is something that
people want these things to last for
months or years so you have to be very
careful about how you schedule your
operations so the basic way this is done
today is the programmer sits down and
says okay I'm here's a static schedule
for every node in the network very
simple every in seconds every second I'm
going to wake up sample my sensor listen
for a while receive some data from other
nodes combine it together and transmit a
new message so it's just a very simple
periodic schedule that every node
performs and of course the periodicity
of the scheduled affects all these
things the accuracy the radio bandwidth
usage the battery lifetime but of course
this is really suboptimal because it's
not necessarily the case that every node
should perform every action at exactly
the same rate it should depend very much
on what's actually happening in the
network we'd like the schedule the set
of operations that every node performs
to depend on sort of the stimulus from
the environment if you will so for what
the one of the goals of our work is what
I call self scheduling which is node
should determine their own schedule
based on their local state such as where
whether or not the vehicle is nearby if
the vehicle is nowhere near by I should
probably not be taking very frequent
sensor readings because it's not giving
me any useful information likewise if
I'm this node way out on the corner of
the network I probably shouldn't be
listening to my radio all that
frequently for incoming radio messages
because no one's going to send me
anything
ok so the individual nodes should decide
what they're going to do based on their
local state not some sort of regimented
global schedule that was defined by the
programmer and secondly we want the
notes to adapt to changing conditions
for example if a vehicle comes near me I
probably should ramp up the rate at
which I sample my sensor to get better
data about that vehicle once the
vehicles moved away and I'm not getting
good data about it I should ramp down my
sampling rate so that I'm not wasting
energy taking sensor readings that are
useless so there's two things going on
we want the notes to specialize their
behavior and we want them to adapt over
time ok and doing this kind of simple
static scheduling which is the standard
technique today doesn't achieve either
of those goals so far so good you can
interrupt me with questions if you have
them ok so when we started thinking
about this problem as I said earlier the
inspiration was coming from ideas and
economics and working with David parks I
wanted to ask the question what could we
use ideas from economic so it's a little
bit about putting the cart before the
horse I'll admit that that there are
many other techniques we could use to
address this problem we decided to take
a economic model first just to see where
we would go with it and I'll show you in
a few minutes that we've actually moved
into some other areas like reinforcement
learning so why might we want to use
economics in the first place well the
reason it seemed attractive from the
beginning was that first of all markets
tend to operate in a decentralized
fashion that we don't necessarily have
centralized control of what all the
agents are doing in a market individuals
are making their own decisions based on
their observation of the environment so
this seems to map well onto the sensor
network secondly the individual nodes
they're just being very greedy and
they're they're trying to in some sense
make more profit if you will and I'll
describe later what I mean by that but
this seems to map well onto a
decentralized process we want to avoid
centralized algorithms here for obvious
reasons which is the communication
overheads would probably make that very
non scalable we don't want to centralize
how this is done and finally there's a
lot of theory about economics that talks
about
how markets realize globally efficient
resource allocations and I don't want to
claim that it's just you know we shut
the door on that problem from a sensor
network perspective but because there's
so much great theoretical work on using
economic ideas for distributed
optimization we thought hey let's try
this out in a sensor network context so
Mike well minute university of michigan
has been doing some work on this area
not in a sensor network context but what
he has he has the system called market
oriented programming and the idea is to
use a market to control a distributed
system and to achieve some kind of
distributed optimization and so his
system does rely on a centralized
process to set prices and i'll get back
into some of this later but we were
inspired by some of this work as we said
hey we could potentially apply these
ideas to sensor networks yes economic
theory assume that information is
globally known it's just that what local
is your your local of perspective that's
true so so one of the things that for
example most market work assumes is that
everybody knows what the prices are okay
it's a good point and I'm going to get
back into how we manage this later on
but you could really imagine doing this
in a decentralized fashion where
individuals don't have global
information it may yield less optimal
solutions but we still think we can move
forward with that but that that's
definitely a good point let me keep
going and then I'll get into the details
and all this will make more sense so we
have this programming model or this
resource allocation model that we call
market-based macro programming and what
I mean by macro programming is this idea
of let's control the global behavior of
the whole network rather than program
the individual devices okay so this is
kind of a research agenda of mine and
the basic model in the market-based
macro programming is that the individual
sensor nodes are acting as agents that
sell goods and a good could be defined
in a number of ways for example a sensor
reading is a good the ability to
transmit a radio message that's another
good okay so depending on the
application we could define a set of
goods every good
is produced by some action that
generates the good so for example taking
a sense of reading turning on the sensor
generates a sensor reading good turning
on the radio to listen for an incoming
radio message may or may not produce a
sense radio message good because if
nobody sends me a radio message while
I've got the radio on I may not get one
but if I do get one that I've now got a
radio message good so far so good so to
speak anyway now every action of course
has some energy costs associated with it
so the main thing that we're concerned
about in this work for now is energy I'm
not talking so much about radio
bandwidth although that's very important
problem mainly going to talk about
energy so the energy costs for each
action that a sensor node can take it
actually varies a enormous amount over
multiple orders of magnitude so for
example sampling a sensor is very cheap
but turning on the radio to transmit a
radio message consumes many many many
more jewels just because of the nature
of the hardware yeah energy rather than
bandwidth that energy is a local
resource abandoned in the Commons that
everybody can village that's one reason
it's easier to start with energy because
it is a local resource but i think these
ideas we could apply them to bandwidth
as well you just have to have a notion
of how much local bandwidth was
available in some sense the bandwidth is
this you have tragically cummins right i
mean if you're using yes no profit
optimization then it's always in some
local nodes best interest to steal
bandwidth unless there's energy
constraint
right or it may be the case that you
actually have a artificial constraint
where nodes wish to achieve fairness
across their neighbors and so they
actually are incentivized to share
bandwidth you could do that too okay
okay so one thing that I want to point
out here is that we're not assuming
self-interested nodes we're not assuming
that random people are programming their
nodes in order to be greedy and get the
best thing out of the network and so you
wrote them no programming thang it's
just not clear to me that the not
knowing anything about market theory
it's not clear markets market three
would hold up if you started adding
constraints like that but it actually
does you can do it not whale I'll talk
some more later but I think it's
important to point out what we're doing
is we're programming nodes to be self
interested in a particular way okay
we're not we're not assuming malicious
behavior in other words which makes life
a lot easier okay so finally every good
has an Associated price so if i turn on
my radio to listen for an incoming radio
message and i do receive an incoming
radio message I now produce that good I
get paid for it and make some profit
okay and the way we program the network
the way we cause the network to take
actions is basically by setting prices
for all the different goods and that's
it okay I'm going to get into the
details again in a second but just this
is the basic idea
I'll let me get to that in a second okay
yes what would be the utility of the
data well let me let me get it I'm going
to get into the details i'll show you in
a second yeah okay so the basic idea is
that the nodes are now just trying to
maximize their profit they're trying to
make the most money but they have a
limited amount of energy to use to make
money okay so it's pretty simple pretty
simple model so the first thing is where
are the prices come from in this work
what we're assuming is that we can
globally advertise the price information
to assumptions here first that it's that
it's possible to do that efficiently and
it turns out that there's a bunch of
protocols out there gossip protocols for
disseminating global information in a
sensor network and that can be done
pretty efficiently secondly that the
prices don't change too often so in
other words we don't have to do that all
that much so so that what we would use
is some protocol there's something
called trickle there's a bunch of other
particles out there that would let me
basically efficiently propagate this
global price information everywhere it's
also important to note that the prices
are small it's not like sending a bunch
of information out there it's like we
have five actions and we'll have five
prices so it's you know a few bytes of
information it's not a lot okay I'm
going to get into that later on for now
I'm not changing the prices yet i'm
going to show you in a minute how we
evaluate this but we're starting we're
basically setting the prices once and
then doing an evaluation ok so what the
nodes do then is they've got this price
information and what they're trying to
do is try to make the most profit so
what they do is they evaluate the
utility function for each action ok and
they pick the action that has the
highest utility yes off subject but just
now they're the tokens the other room
about selfish ain't working together and
let you get together have this will you
may be one in the other side of the room
okay well so so what the utility is
there's several things in utility and
I'll show you some math in a minute but
basically the utilities in is a function
of the price of the action of course the
amount of energy availability so if I
have a little bit of energy available
but such action takes a huge amount of
energy then I can't take that action so
it basically has no utility to me and
other dependencies data dependencies on
the action so for example the action to
aggregate multiple items multiple sensor
readings together into a new sensor
reading I'm not allowed to take that
until I have acquired multiple sensor
readings right so there's a data
dependency that has to be met likewise
I'm not allowed to transmit a radio
message until I have something to
transmit it seems obvious but you have
to include that in the model okay so the
energy budget there's a lot of different
ways that we could model this we chose a
simple token bucket scheme and the basic
idea is that a node has some total
capacity of energy that it is allowed to
store up you could think of this as your
battery capacity or if you have a
capacitor or something that's storing
energy for you that's the total amount
of energy you're allowed to hoard and
taking actions drains that energy energy
down so every action has an energy costs
as I said and the bucket refills with
energy at some rate row and the rate is
chosen by the system designer to
basically give the lifetime of the
network for example if I give a rate of
a thousand joules a day that's putting a
bound on how much energy a node can
consume I'm telling a node look you
can't consume more than a thousand
joules a day so if you start out with
you know ten thousand joules that gives
you ten days of lifetime this makes
sense so it's a very simple model but
there's other ways you could do this as
well now let me talk about what the
utility function really is the utility
function that we're using is incredibly
simple and we could add all kinds of
more
complicated things we actually started
with something that was fairly more
sophisticated than this and it turned
out that it didn't work so well and I'll
get into that in a minute but the
utility that we're using is the for each
action the utility of the action is the
expected profit and the expected profit
is simply the price of the action times
the probability that you're going to get
paid if you take the action so remember
what I said earlier about if you take an
action you may or may not produce a good
so if I turn on the radio to listen for
an incoming radio message someone may
not send me a radio message so I may not
actually get paid for that that action
meaning I wasted the energy right so the
utility represents my expected profit if
the price is 10 and fifty percent of the
time i get paid my expected profit is
five ok yes so this probability that
you're going to get paid every time you
take the action you update the
probability and we use a simple you
could do this a lot of ways we just use
a simple exponentially weighted moving
average yeah it's um did you get his
feedback whether somebody will just look
for you that's right so well actually
it's the other way around if I turn on
my radio to listen go for listening but
if you talk oh you know somebody's
listening yeah so we just we just assume
that at the mac layer of the radio that
there's an acknowledgement that goes
back ok so this feedback that you
brought this up thank you for bringing
that up that's very important in this
model that the note actually knows when
it took an action that was profitable ok
so let me give you another example just
to make it clear if I take a sense of
reading and the sensor reading is very
weak and it doesn't tell me that the
vehicle is nearby I don't get paid for
that either it was a useless as a waste
of energy so what a note is doing by
getting this feedback as its determining
whether or not the thing that it did was
a useful thing to do yeah pays for the
information the other node that receives
it
some global God the way we do it right
now is very simple the notes basically
pay themselves remember we're not
assuming that knows are trying to cheat
here so there's no reason that they
would so they basically know when I take
an action they know okay I got paid for
that where I didn't get paid for that so
they pay themselves it is true that you
could imagine some actions where a node
would be unable to pay itself because it
needs some other information from
another note for example I don't know if
I send some stream of sensor readings
and the eye base station put them
together and said oh yeah that was
useful I guess it could issue a payment
later on back to the node but now you
have a feedback loop that's got some
delay in it for this very simple model
the note immediately knows whether it
was paid keep in mind that as I said
earlier the utility function is
conditioned by these dependencies on the
action there's two dependencies whether
or not I have enough of energy available
to take the action and whether or not
the data dependencies have been met so
the utility function could be zero for
an action if neither of those conditions
are true okay so this is a very very
simple model but there's a problem with
it the problem is that a node look that
learns that an action is unprofitable
will never do whatever again it'll say
well the beta went to 0 because I never
got paid for turning on my radio to
listen for incoming radio messages so
you know the heck with that I'm not
going to listen for radio messages
anymore i'm not getting paid for it
that's bad right we don't want notes to
get trapped in some local minima where
they don't where they don't look for
other opportunities for profit remember
that we're assuming the network is
dynamic so the vehicles moving around
the network so if I'm taking sensor
readings and not seeing the vehicle that
doesn't mean it's never going to happen
in the future so I really want to be
exploring for new opportunities for
profit I don't want to just stay stuck
in one state so the way we do this is a
fancy term called epsilon greedy
reinforcement learning which is really a
fancy way of saying most of the time I
take the action with the highest utility
but sometimes I take a random action ok
so it's think of like simulated
annealing or something sometimes I go
uphill
their past performance is no guarantee
of you sure that's the disclaimer on
your etrade yes that's humor Prime yes
i'm in a world that right years prior
there's a lawsuit I so long as I said at
the bottom well I guess I said machine
learning at the bottom there's lots of
other ways that we could do this this is
the chapter 2 of Sutton bartow I mean
this is very simple but we chose it to
be very simple because it seems to work
well we didn't want to do anything more
complicated until we'd understood this
one yeah with this random action be a
good Russian article scope probe is
getting drunk from time to time yes
alright but it's very simple and so it's
now doing as a note is mostly taking the
action and so think of this epsilon
parameter here as the i'm going to pick
something that i don't know it to be
profitable i'm going to turn on my radio
even though i don't think that there's
any incoming radio messages but hey if
there is an incoming radio message i'm
going to learn very rapidly that that
was profitable okay so by taking random
actions i'm potentially wasting energy i
might be doing things that are wasting
energy but i am looking for new
opportunities for profit there are so
many interesting machine learning
algorithms we could use to tune this
system i'm doing this very simple one
right now for example the dumbest one
you could name is tune that parameter
epsilon over time based on what seems to
be happening okay let me give you an
example just to show you what the
utility functions look like so the node
down here in the corner of the network
I've got four actions shown here
listening for incoming radio messages
sampling the sensor aggregating data
which is taking multiple sensor readings
and combining them into one and
transmitting data and just as an
illustration this is not actual data was
just an illustration this note down here
has a low utility for listening for
incoming radio messages because there's
nobody near it that's going to transmit
to it but he's close to the vehicle so
he has a high utility for sampling
aggregation and transmission okay
another node in the network like this
guy here has a high utility for
listening because other nodes are
routing data through it now we didn't
set these parameters they're learned by
the nodes
okay they start out at a random value
they learn these it's not near the
vehicle so he doesn't have any reason to
sample it sensor but it does have high
high points for aggregating and
transmitting because data is coming
through it that it has an opportunity to
aggregate and transmit and finally this
node down here it doesn't have a high
utility for anything so the good news is
he'll save his energy he won't most of
the time he's not going to do anything
he's going to sleep that's exactly what
we want okay keep in mind we didn't
actually program all this behavior in
some sense we set up the conditions and
set the prices and the nodes are
learning what to do so that's kind of
the kind of the beauty of it in the
notes this is very simple if you're
asking the question well gee you're
doing this economics and reinforcement
learning and you've got sense remotes
and they got 8-bit processors and 4k of
RAM are you out of your mind I mean this
is actually very simple to implement
there's very little state that a node's
node needs to maintain all the stuff can
be done with cheap operations this is
not we're not doing it's one reason
we're not doing really sophisticated
reinforcement learning techniques that
require lots of state and building a
model and all this kind of fun stuff
because we don't have the memory for it
so there's an interesting question about
how sophisticated could we get but we
want it to keep it really simple
secondly the nodes are going to adapt so
these are these utility functions are
going to change over time based on
what's happening to a note it's going to
learn its beta parameter and as the
vehicle moves around the network its
utility for different actions is going
to change so this is not a static asana
this is not a static optimization
problem it's fairly been any right so
far the prime talking in the condition
where the prices aren't changing I'll
get to a let me get to that in a few
slides I think I'm gonna talk about
changing prices change based on how much
energy you have one
good maybe I missed something okay this
is this is the question I meant it I
meant to address that earlier i'm sorry
so you're going to notice here that
energy is not part of the utility
function directly it's an indirect thing
which is if i don't have enough energy
utility is 0 what a note is not doing is
directly trying to value energy it's not
saying well I've got a really high
energy costs action a really low energy
costs action which one should I take now
so you always spend it if you got it so
I spend it if I got that means if
something has a tiny fraction of
probability of being profitable and it
costs you know any energy like well yeah
I can afford that long as I have it yes
that's just that's just two things one
is nodes will never sleep it's not there
I'll show you in a minute they're going
to burn energy there at the rate they
can and the second thing that suggests
is that there you're always going to
perform the cheapest operation first if
multiple things are available and you
never get around to be able to afford
the expensive one because you're
spending your pennies best right okay
that's a great that's this is a very
good point so the first one in terms of
never sleeping in fact they do sleep
when they don't have enough energy to
take any action that has a nonzero
utility I need to point this out if I if
all my utilities are zero because you
know nothing's happening around me I'm
going to sleep by default vanishingly
small did that one know that had like
no utility in Brussels yeah Oh actually
I'm sorry I should explain it will we do
to be threshold that so if the utilities
below some small value we set it to zero
you subtract the revenue from the cost
of your mulling the revenue but you're
not modeling the cost and it seems like
you'd want to model the costume okay so
thank you this is what I need to was
going to explain so we tried that first
and that was our original model it
didn't work very well for the following
reason basically the energy costs for
different actions as i said earlier
varies very widely so taking a sample
action consumes like miniscule amount of
energy transmitting a radio message
spends thousands and thousands of times
more energy than that so what ends up
happening is say i sample my sensor a
few times and I notice the vehicles
nearby suddenly by using a tiny bit of
energy i get huge profit for the amount
of energy that i used so I overvalue my
energy meaning that I never transmitted
so it's all yeah so one way of fixing
that is to play with the prices but what
we decided to do was even simpler which
is to say look it's all about this
energy budget I have no problem with how
nodes are going to use their energy they
can use their energy any way they want
as long as they stay within the bucket
you said well they're never going to
sleep because you know they're just
going to burn all their energy good
they're supposed to burn their energy
within this limit row here there's no
problem with that you do this picture
where the guys in the core networks
we're sleeping you know kind of in a
sense of saving their energy up for the
time when they have to do something but
they're not going to do that right i
mean yes I well because the threshold
because of the threshold on a
are you going to have the other effect
where I imagine like the buckets manteca
I'm sleeping now we get a little bit of
energy trickling into my bucket at this
rate yes the only thing we'll bill to do
one of the flow energy is exact okay so
that's what I want immediately use that
up and go back to sleep and so you'll
never get that shorty in your bucket to
actually do something that is the more
serious problem let me address that
first which is our current skiing is as
you can tell extremely myopic the note
is not faking into the future and saying
well hey if I saved a little more energy
I could take that more profitable action
it's saying I've got this much energy
i'm going to use it it's like the kid
you give them the allowance and he goes
and spends it at the most what i did is
a kid anyway you just spend the three
dollars right now instead of saving it
for next week or you get ten dollars so
certainly that's an issue there's ways
of fixing that obviously which is just
to build a little bit more complexity
into the learning scheme so nodes can
reason into the future about what profit
they might have in the future if they
were to allow energy to store up in a
minute seems to work anyway I would not
going to say it's optimal I'm just gonna
say it it actually happens to work hey
two things one is basically the business
of book would be the sampling you should
really reduce a value of an extra sample
immediately after the first raid yes
right moving that fast and the second
say yes the money you have will work if
you have a solar cell and it gets
charged you run off a fixed battery
seems a pretty bad karma because you
know you spend all your and enjoy
chitchat the battery flap for the 10
come well the way we do that is is again
I mean this capacity see we can pick
that to be whatever we want doesn't have
to be a the capacity of a solar cell we
could simply say you know even though
we're running off a battery say we're
running off a fixed power source we
could set the capacity the depth of the
bucket to be some limited amount meaning
you're not allowed to hoard more energy
than some amount of it so tell your moto
says when you pocket your bed you quite
yes that capacity is Nick passing the
whole battery
example he gave earlier was that maybe
the bucket only holds 500 rules but
you've got a 10,000 jewel battery okay
really feel it but your virgin you're
virtually filling the bucket but you're
not like empty hallway that's right
that's right Matt so how when you're
filling the bucket I mean what's the
quanta which you're dropping step into
the bucket so really exhibits I think I
kind of not sure if I understand what
you mean but every time you take an
action you deduct something from the
bucket and then you look at how much
time you've spent know you you do it you
do it continuously continuously
continuous okay so the big question I
was originally gonna ask haha let's go
people starting the case use it every
time you take an action you I'm sorry
determine when it finishes it's in the
case so you said if you're taking action
you look at how long a spin and sort of
fill up appropriately yes what if you're
not take what if you're sleeping at what
point then you go to put something I
think I'm not sure exactly what the
import of the question is I mean
basically when you what we do when you
go to sleep is you sleep for some fixed
length of time so it's not like you
sleep forever and sleep for say a second
or half a second I mean when you wake up
you say okay I supper half second so
this is how much energy i now have in my
bucket I'm just I'm still trying to get
back to how does a bucket never have
enough energy to let you do something
expensive it works and I think this may
be the reason that it worse as you sleep
for a second if that accumulation of
energy let you do something expensive
and that'll solve the bunny let me if
you don't mind let me go on because i'm
going to show you the operation of this
and i think it will address some of
these questions yes yes there were I'm
sorry Adam worry about the converse
properly often problem so they're
talking about as you get a penny you
spend it immediately yes imagine let's
say you start you've got a thousand
rules yes we've got this nice big bucket
of energy and then you discover that its
profitable
so what prevents it and suddenly just
sampling at maximum rate old bucket is
empty because now it's found this proper
black in other words there's no models
worth there's an opportunity cost for
using energy because there might be
something to buy this is a detail any
problems that have explained that you're
right you need to be careful about this
one thing is there's a limited amount of
memory that a node can use to store
sample so if it buffers up say a
thousand samples it's out of memory so
it's not gonna that action is no longer
going to be profitable so it stops doing
that one way of doing it profitable
operation being repeated over and over
yes again that assumes actually that no
one is not valuing the major problem so
right and that would not happen if
they're always getting a feedback from
its neighbors if it was paid by the
neighbors for the information because
yeah I don't know would say okay you
already told me that you're ready to
sing a tank I don't care if you're
seeing it again that's right tell me
what you're not seeing it that's what I
want to hear there's another that's one
way of doing it another way of doing it
is just to throw in another constraint
which is you know if I've sampled more
than 10 times in a row there's no new
information to be gained by doing it
more so I'm gonna stop doing that now
okay let me go on I'm going to show you
how this works yeah I think these are
very good suggestions though we have
played with some of these ideas the
other thing is a little bit interesting
here and we didn't expect this but once
you think about it it makes sense but
the fact that notes are getting feedback
based on which actions were successful
means that there's some natural balance
or equilibrium I don't mean like
economic equilibrium but I mean natural
balance in the system about what
fraction of nodes are doing what so for
example the number of nodes listening
for incoming radio messages tends to be
in balance with the number of nodes that
have something to transmit meaning that
if I've got very little to transmit
right now nodes are not turning on the
radio to listen for incoming messages
because they learned in the past that it
wasn't profitable to do so so they power
down the radio so one way of thinking
about this is we accidentally
implemented some of these duty cycling
radio you know radio ad hoc duty cycling
protocols we didn't mean to do that but
it happened sort of emerged
from the way the system was built and
I've already mentioned that you can
control the network with prices there's
a question about how general that is it
with our current scheme it's very simple
so it's not obvious to me that you could
get any perform any behavior over the
network just by setting different prices
but i'm going to show you in a minute we
haven't told the system here that it's
tracking vehicles we see basically set
for prices and we set the for prices out
and notes do stuff so the question is
how you know what what range of
behaviors came to get out of the network
just by changing the prices and nothing
else alright the way we evaluated this
initially was in simulation and we have
a this is using the toss in tiny wet
simulation environment so it's very very
detailed simulator it's gets down to the
hardware level remote so we actually
believe that this is fairly reasonable
it doesn't abstract away too much we
have a hundred notes here and the
vehicle is moving in this circular path
here at some rate so we just wanted to
excite different parts of the network by
moving it around in a circle moving in a
circle meant it was deterministic so we
could know we could we could run
multiple runs in the vehicle be in the
same place each time and the nodes use
this these green lines show the routing
pads we're using GPS are which is a
simple geographic routing protocol to do
the routing so the first oh and before I
go on we needed to compare this to
something it's a little tricky what do
you compare this to exactly it's not
like we can go pluck some you know
random vehicle tracking code from
somewhere and it's going to run and make
sense and do the same thing so we tried
our best to implement what we thought
represented the other way of doing note
scheduling which is as I said earlier
the static schedule where nodes are
basically given a fixed rate at which
they perform the actions so that was the
first one we implemented some people on
the first paper submission said well
this is a straw man you should do
something more complicated so we did
dynamic scheduling which is a node looks
at its energy availability and it two
turns up and down the rate at which it
does the schedule based on the amount of
energy available note that I don't know
of any actual sensor network that does
this so i think we probably could have
published a paper just on that
but it's very simple so it's it's not
much of a contribution but it's a little
bit more advanced than what's done today
finally we implemented you so many you
know Camille White House at Berkeley he
has this system called hoods which is a
way of implementing vehicle tracking
systems and so we read the paper and the
code very carefully and we basically
borrowed the we didn't take the code
exactly what we re implemented the same
tracker that they evaluate in their
paper so that's really meant to
represent another published paper that
does vehicle tracking okay yes so if you
hold the nodes around if you turn off
fail Georgia better we're not looking in
those cases here anyway in terms of
moving the nose around and having them
fail but the Thai mean by not dynamic
note scheduling is a node looks at the
amount of it so let me let me make sure
I'm clear here depending on where the
note is in the network it's going to get
excited to take different actions so
different nodes use more or less energy
so in the dynamic scheduling case the
nodes that have used more and more of
their energy budget have less energy to
spend so they scale back the rate at
which they perform actions so every node
is trying to meet some energy target
daily energy target and they're doing
that by individually picking the rate at
which they run this program okay so some
initial results question is all right
can we track vehicles and how accurate
is it so the this is a CDF the the
tracking event error in meters is shown
here and this means what I mean by this
is when the base station receives the
estimate of the vehicles location how
far is the vehicle from that true
location and remember the vehicles
constantly moving so it's going to have
some error anyway based on when you know
vehicles move during the time that the
date has been routed to the base station
and this is the the CDF so the first
thing to note is the the yellow and the
green lines are the static and
dynamically scheduled trackers that we
implement it kind of the standard way of
doing things and it's we see they get
the best performance so they're pretty
accurate the hood system the black line
here is one of the least accurate and
that's basically because it uses a
particular way of of aggregating data
that tends to lose information so it
wasn't actually a very good tracking
algorithm as it turns out and the red
blue green and purple lines here
represent the market-based approach with
different settings for the price for
listening for incoming radio messages so
we did was we just set the all the
prices for the other actions to be the
same value and we turn the knob on one
of the prices and then ran it over and
over and over again to get these lines
and what we what we see is
if the price for listen action is 15
which is you know in some you know
relationship to the other prices then
the performance of the tracker is pretty
good it's almost as good as the
statically scheduled version ok I want
to point out first of all that my goal
here is not to get a more accurate
tracking algorithm i'm going to show you
in a minute that what we achieve with
this is far better energy efficiency
okay but we're close so we're ballpark
in terms of being able to track the
vehicle but if i turn up the price or
turn down the price for the lips in
action then I have some degradation in
performance so lesson number one prices
matter and the question now is how do i
set the price it's a big open question
so something that we're still working on
but one thing you're going to notice
here the listen price for zero means
that note should never turn on their
radio to listen for incoming radio
messages so how on earth is any data
getting to the base station well the
base station is assumed to be powered
and always listening for incoming radio
messages so what's happening is these
this data is only being received from
the nodes that are right next to the
base station okay so there's still some
data there
let me give you a picture of how the
market-based moat is running using this
algorithm so this is a fairly
complicated diagram times on the x-axis
the actions taken by the node this is
looking at one node are shown here so
there's a dot when in action so at this
point in time the note took an aggregate
action what's happening is this is a
node that's along the vehicles path and
the vehicle is far away and it's moving
near the node and then it's driving on
and it's moving away okay so moving
along that circular path so at this time
here the vehicle approaches and the
green line shows the probability of
payment for taking sensor readings which
as we would expect shoots up when the
vehicles nearby and drops back down when
the vehicle moves away during the time
that the vehicle is nearby the node
spends less of its time listening for
incoming radio messages because it's
suddenly being paid a lot more to
aggregate and transmit its data to the
base station because it now it has data
to send your honor being your own
samples together so the other choice you
either get to take a sample and transmit
it or take several samples aggregate
them together and transmit it but
there's a caveat here which is because
this node gets very excited it starts
using more if its energy so its energy
budget drops down to zero which means
that it has to sleep so this is a little
funny it means that because transmitting
consumes so much radio energy so much
battery so much energy it means I'm now
sort of forced to to sleep during the
during the time that it mattered the
most okay so maybe what we want to do
here is think about you know allowing
the node to hoard a little bit more
energy and maybe use a different energy
reserve for times when it's excited or
something like that there's some
interesting questions about how to fix
this problem yeah listen there seems
concerning is what if you're on the base
station side of the vehicles path which
means now all the base stations hearing
is your report and it would like to also
be getting information from your
neighbors but
you're not being very helpful here
because that's that's absolutely right
so the way to fix that of course is to
bring the prices for listen and
aggregation and transmission more within
the same range so that the node will do
more of those things the way the prices
are set here I don't remember the exact
values but they were nodes were given
priority to transmit and aggregate over
listening yes you're estimating the
probability of being paid yes so I think
I understand in each case except for
aggregation with what that is so i guess
and listen you you measure how many
times people pack here and I rate the
probability being paid for it is I'm
trying to remember I think it's possible
that you always get paid to do that
because there's no condition there it's
basically I aggregate values together
and in this case what we're doing is
we're taking the maximum sensor reading
from all the sent all the values that
I've collected so you always get paid to
aggregate so beta is always one let me
keep going is I don't want to run too
much out of time yes I'll get to energy
buddy shoot up what was a tank was
approaching that's interesting well
what's happening here is the note
initially spent more and more of its
time sampling it's not quite at the
point where it's transmitting yet
because it's sampling and it's
aggregating so it hasn't started sensing
yet the listen action consumes a fair
amount of energy it's doing less of that
so it's basically boarding more energy
we didn't tell it to do this it's just
evaluating these utility functions in
learning the beta parameters I mean this
is this is not programmed behavior this
is emergent all right one thing that we
can do with prices that's kind of
interesting is by giving different nodes
different sets of prices we can cause
them to behave very differently so for
example we could take say ten percent of
the nodes in the network and give them
prices just for listening and
transmitting data and those are now
routers the prices for the other actions
are zero what's that yeah we just
randomly pick ten percent okay and we
can give all the other nodes simply
prices for sampling and transmission so
they're just simple sensors they're dumb
all right so simply by giving them
different price vectors they behave
differently and this is just showing
over time the proportion of actions
taken by each by each set of notes so
this is an interesting way of in some
sense controlling Network behavior just
by assigning different prices oh yes
interesting to see whether you can
actually engineer this behavior by
itself meaning i think in order comments
or is that if you have feedback right
uh-huh and i can imagine the kind of
interesting behavior you see would be
four sensors in a region which has a lot
of activity yes then perhaps say twenty
percent of sensors were not sample an
extended or something else that I can
actually specialize two different loads
because over sampling a region is
redundant that's right now that's only a
chi is the possible if you have feedback
of sense Italian chela that I'm seeing
very similar data as you c and f what's
so correlated and if i should go to do
something else that's right and I wonder
if but that kind of collaborative
behavior you can actually engineer use
these this is something that we're
working on which has to do with those
basically changing the prices within the
network so no could tell its neighbors
hey this is my state so you should
affect your own utility function in the
following way so that we don't have
redundant actions or you know hey if I'm
noticing something interesting all you
guys should start sampling more
frequently even though you don't think
you should I'm going to induce you to do
that more because we think something
interesting is happening nearby it seems
like that that would be the essential
feature
the marketplace in other words the
teenage it's not really a market plate
these aren't really markets and since
they're all individual they don't
interact with each other right so far we
don't have yet as i'm going to get to
this in a minute this is i haven't
presented really a notion of a market so
much as a reinforcement learning based
scheduling technique this is an emergent
because everybody prints their own money
nobody spends it that's not really
necessary as it turns out from the
economics literature point of view
spending money is not necessary who's
spending the money is the base station
base stations spending money by the
notice being paid to take these actions
so from the economics the pure abstract
theoretical point of view it is market
yes so from the economic principles you
should not be doing you should not be
enforcing a caste system like this the
note should specialize on their own
based on just the market prices and so
on you should not be forcing them to be
routers or sensors you're right about
that what yes and we actually have a
student working on exactly that approach
which is how do the nodes effectively go
to get the notes to pay each other to
act as it so I you can pay me in a life
as a router for you we're working on
that right now I'm just showing this is
an example of by setting the prices by
hand what you can accomplish all right I
promise that the main goal here was
really energy efficiency so I'm going to
try to illustrate that the this is a
graph of the total energy used by
individual nodes in the network over
time so each dot means that at this
moment in time some node in the network
had consumed up to that amount of energy
okay there's a hundred nodes of the
network so there's a lot of thoughts the
energy budget that thousand joules per
day is this purple line here so that's
the cap that's the total amount that
it's allowed to use the static
scheduling I'm sorry the static
scheduling is the blue line here and
what you're going to notice is it
doesn't hug the line because every node
was pre-programmed to say well I'm going
to take a set of actions over some
interval
but if say for example i turn on my
radio and no data comes in then I don't
have anything to aggregate or transmit
so I don't need to do those actions so
I'm conservative in other words I may
not use all my energy budget doing the
static scheduling I'm a undershoot the
dynamic scheduling though proactively
tries to hug the line and as you see it
does that okay so exactly it's doing
what it's supposed to do but what's
happening here in the market-based
approach is that a lot of nodes are
using very very little energy because
they haven't been excited to do anything
else they're basically saving energy
because they haven't learned that it
would be profitable for them to sample
or two transmitter to do anything else
so they're saving a lot of energy but
you saw earlier that you know these two
systems are using a lot more energy but
they got roughly roughly the same
accuracy in terms of the tracking
another way of thinking about this is
efficiency and my metric here and I
think this is a very important metric to
think about is the the efficiency the
energy efficiency of the system is the
total energy used to actually collect
meaningful sensor data at the base
station meaning data that resulted in
position estimates of the vehicle being
tracked useful data divided by the total
amount of energy used by all the nodes
of the network okay so for example every
know that that listens and receives a
message and forwards it to the base
station and samples and all that energy
is counted as being useful energy energy
that resulted in the base station
learning something all the other energy
that was used was wasted energy because
it didn't result in new data arriving at
the base station for example if i turn
on my radio to listen for an incoming
radio message and nothing comes in that
was wasted energy does this make sense
so far yes why do the infusions
go up when you supply more energy using
what you most both things get less
efficient the use of their I'm gonna
I'm going to tell you let me let me
explain this and I'll tell you okay so
if you look at the numbers here what we
did was we took two energy budgets one
which is a thousand joules per day in
another which is three thousand joules
per day and what we see is in all cases
where more energy efficient meaning the
nodes waste less energy now the reason
they do this is that they're dynamically
tuning the rate at which they do each
action based on whether it was
profitable so they're learning not to
waste energy this is not incredibly
efficient but of course neither of these
okay this ninety-five percent efficiency
that means that only five percent of the
energy used by the whole network was
wasted in data not arriving at the base
station that's an amazing that's amazing
result the reason that they become more
efficient when you provide them a bigger
energy budget is that they are less
constrained by the actions they can take
when the energy budget is three thousand
joules per day it's effectively
unlimited meaning that problem we
discussed earlier where a node would
take the really low energy actions
because that's all the energy it has
doesn't happen here so that suggests
that this is a problem that we do need
to solve okay other tools will increase
in efficiency but they're doing
something very very similar of in fact
this is this is not much of an increase
yeah but have you ever plotted curves
that trade-off energy and precision
because you can pursue the average
energy that yeah we had a lot of stuff
upon this in our paper
yeah I mean the more energy available
the much better the results are I mean
equal persons one of the Kings the other
police are spending some energy and
giving you some precision top so you
have it into something two graphs with
you could somehow put them on the same
graphic compute the average energy being
spent and as you increase the increase
the average energy i get bored Weber
State I think we have these graphs in
the paper look like and what are the
interest yet it's very difficult we
don't have a we have points we don't
have full curves because each one of
these simulations takes hours to run and
so we haven't tested with all the
possible points it would we just put
much if you have some magic like a bit
precision per Joule yes bright magic and
the padishah cannot use that to
engineers all ages the behavior when
this aging take action yes if it's a two
ingredient percent in the hockey haha
not afraid that's not that's the local
gradient where you want to establish yes
yes if you believe economics is a
business of allocating scarce a
relatively scarce resources this surly
six percent means something is badly
broken with you with you at occasion one
another at a point seven wet but what is
probably happening here because the
thought is again it's a thousand joules
per day it's a very limited energy
budget the nodes are effectively the
exploration costs of doing actions that
were potentially not profitable is
hurting them more the random stuff is
hurting them oil we think that the code
of the energy goes and random stuff
because that's only if that is now let
me tell you another reason point okay
you have to keep in mind counting the
useful energy is only data that
eventually arrived at the base station
so here's the problem the low energy
budget not enough notes may turn on
their radio because they don't have
enough energy to do it so if I generate
data and transmit it to you and you're
not listening wasted energy oh this
isn't taking you to
counting how many packets arrive big
what I mean utility what so from
what you just said it sounds like if you
take if you just sample all the time and
transmit all that data back all the time
then you'd be a hundred percent
efficiency even if the tag never went
through the
so this is not you know for that matter
if you only transiently right except for
what's happening is we're only
transmitting data for I mean the sense
the samples of Windows tanks nowhere
near body rejected by the nodes anyway
so they never get transmitted part of
the getting paid for doing that action
let me keep going because I want to
finish up here but let me talk briefly
about where we're going with this so
what am I mainly talking about here is a
case where the nodes are adaptively
learning their schedule now that going
back to markets and wait what you just
said about you know allocating scarce
resources that's really what this should
be about which is we've got multiple
competing users fighting over scarce
resources we want to allocate those
resources in a decentralized fashion so
this is work in progress is what we're
working on right now the context is I'm
not actually doing vehicle tracking at
Harvard so one of the things we are
doing is medical sensor networks and the
idea here is that you'd have a lot of
different patients outfitted with
wireless sensors that in this case I've
got a an EKG that we developed and a
pulse oximeter both of these are I mean
I can talk to you more about them later
if you're curious but these are vital
signs monitors based on the modes you've
got some other motes maybe these are on
other patients maybe these were fixed in
the building or something okay that
they're there to route data and a doctor
might say for example i want to receive
an update on patient a every 30 seconds
and look at that data on my PDA ok we
have a PDA application it's actually
using dotnet compact framework it's
pretty cool and so that data would get
routed back to the doctor through some
path and we were using a multicast
routing protocol to do that and this EMT
down here may say well I only want to
receive updates on patient be when
they're critical in other words when
their heart rate goes beyond some some
certain percentage and let's say the
data gets routed through this central
node here so now we've obviously got you
know some contention where we've got
limited bandwidth here but we've got to
users that want this data and they're
fighting over this limited pant with an
energy so what we really are working on
right now is using this market-based
idea to
to get true equilibrium in the network
so the idea is every user would specify
utility function as part of their query
now hopefully a nurse or a doctors and
don't have to enter curves and things
like that so we'll have to make that
easy to use but but this allows someone
to express their trade-offs in terms of
the latency or the quality or the rate
of the data that they're getting and
this makes a lot of sense in a medical
context if I can only hear from a
patient once a minute I want to hear you
know heart rate in you know blood oxygen
saturation whereas if I can hear from
them if I'm standing right next to them
and I can get their data you know it at
a very high rate I want the full EKG
signal trees ok so these trade-offs do
make sense so we want to use this nvm
approach to get an efficient
decentralized allocation and the basic
way you do this of course is you find
prices for each action so that the
supply of goods equals the demand of the
goods and that's the definition of
cradle optimality a lot of work has been
done on how to do this in market based
systems using centralized techniques
where you collect the supply information
you collect the demand information you
adjust the prices Yuri advertise the
prices but that's a centralized process
and as I said at the beginning we want
to avoid centralized techniques so how
do you do this well we're going after
some approximations which may not be as
efficient as doing it in a centralized
way but if it is decentralized and
scalable that works well for us so the
idea is that will do things like adjust
the prices within the network and
piggyback the prices on other messages
so that we're not wasting opportunities
to transmit with this overhead hopefully
yeah
it stars varsity necessarily horses of
melody business location in cases where
you are not capable of making it an
incremental decisions incremental
actions for example in the doctor's
office the doctor thinks that the
patient might have a brain tumor the
doctor can take equation to go and have
an MRI the dog doesn't have a cheaper
option doctor cannot do something that's
half the cost of an MRI and get half
hour I see that you're getting at yeah
so so and that post that was sort of
what you were you had in your network
they were sort of wants of information
and one surprising you could get right
and because of that you need to expand
the budget so that it becomes kind of
small this becomes mental terms and we
talked about right right right and I
think that's true even in this large
enough doesn't that's the reason why
there is national debt well I see I mean
yeah so these are things so David and I
have been talking about a lot of these
and it's very interesting because the
theoretical work that's been done in
this area hard to see how it applies in
a sensor network context so we may have
to abandon kind of traditional ways of
thinking about economics and I'm not
wedded to economic so to speak we're
using them as an inspiration but if we
have to develop something different
that's going to work that's good do you
have a question Alec a momentum question
of like on when I think about economic
so
market based algorithms they are
thinking about trying to reach an
equilibrium with individual agents doing
selfishly for example or as a
cooperating cooperative games but very
but in sensor networks you're probably
not going to see Olivia like the tanks
move around is actually creating this
you in disequilibrium that's right then
how you going to actually apply markets
which try to obtain equilibrium to solve
this problem and especially when we have
things days actually correlations it's a
very important thing we're exposed
beyond individual agent that's right and
the column and the coloration as to the
bachelor also change too so so that's
why it's just China understand it's just
the right approach up to date it's good
you're asking the right question I don't
know the answer yet we're kind of going
after this to understand these exact
questions one of the things we do
believe is that we're never going to
actually reach equilibrium where
everybody's perfectly happy and all the
prices are exactly because things are
changing all the time people are moving
around data rates are changing one of
the results that's out there says that
if you have an approximate equilibrium
then you have it gets closer and closer
and closer to optimality okay so that's
a good result that means that if we're
slightly out of equilibrium we're
slightly less efficient than we would
have been have we've been perfect
equilibrium but we're not way on the
other end of the scale and so that's one
thing that we're we're looking for doing
but as I said you know this is kind of
work in progress so you know maybe we're
going to have to abandon this use of
economics if we want it to get it to
really work but this is what we're going
after right now yeah little quick
question
in in this type of scenario actually
missing a critical message has a huge
panel yes I wonder how you tomorrow that
is a penalty as part of the cost or
price you good point so what we have in
mind right now is that we do have some
sort of prioritization scheme where I
can basically say that certain messages
are more important than others and
thereby get paid you pay more for them
so the message that a patient stopped
breathing or their heart stopped is much
more important than some healthy 46 year
old with no history of heart disease
sitting in the sitting in the outpatient
word okay so there is definitely a and
that and hopefully we capture that with
the use of utility functions that's the
idea is that we have some unified way of
expressing our preferences be nice but
that's so that's a better basic model
let me all right we're working on
high-level programming languages which
I'm going to skip this but we'll talk
about it later if you want to talk about
one on one that compiles down into this
model I already mentioned the future
directions the first thing that we're
going after is this idea of richer
pricing and learning models so that for
example we could price sequences of
actions so we could say it's really
valuable if you take several sensor
readings and then combine them together
and then transmit because then nodes
operate less myopically I already
mentioned this idea of using the market
to do multi-user resource allocation and
adjusting the price is obviously this is
this is really important one way we've
been playing with this already is you
could imagine programming certain nodes
in the network as sentries everybody
else is bright note zero price for
everything so they sleep some nodes are
awake and they're paying attention
they're cognizant of the environment and
when they see an interesting event they
propagate new prices to their neighbors
that say hey wake up you need to start
taking action now so the price
propagation can be a form of distributed
control all right so just to wrap up I
mean basically what we're interested in
here is new techniques for doing
resource allocation in sensor nets and
we started with this project thinking
about how do you program a sensor
network using
prices we ended up at a place where we
said well the court the core problem
we're dressing is how do i schedule the
operations of individual nodes
adaptively so that they use their energy
wisely and the main technique that came
out of that was a real simple form of
reinforcement learning going back to the
economic side of things it started
within the context of can we use markets
and economics and so we think that that
problem really comes back when we talk
about multiple users fighting for some
limited bandwidth less interesting on
the individual node scheduling case but
these two do hook together so i think
the the pointers here we have a paper on
this that's going to appear in n SDI and
we also have a position paper about this
idea that we already presented at the
sig ops european workshop and my web
page and email are there so thank you
very much I'll take any other questions
now yes you had one explanation was this
funny behavior which is a at low energy
people talk when others don't listen and
listen when others don't talk that's
obvious fix of that if not do with
pricing but with synchronization look at
the Wilderness protocol to pray you
hands yeah sex is time when people
listen and talk that's right all the
times they don't that's right so when
they meet in playing with it as well is
could notes not learn Justin just a sort
of an expected profit for each action
it's some arbitrary point in time but
learn that over different time slices
time slots so I could learn you know
Fang was sending me messages at these at
some regular interval I would learn that
it was profitable for me to turn on my
radio and listen at these time slots and
I would turn off my radio at other time
so it's kind of self-organizing tdma so
we're actually playing with that idea
and it doesn't require a lot more state
you just have to remember that the beta
for each action at each time time slice
not just for all time but the real
problem that we're having there was not
really that they were not transmitting
listening at the same time it was that
with a low energy budget listening was
too expensive energy wise so fewer nodes
were doing it so less data was getting
through
and so what you want to do there
obviously is you know raise the price
for listening to cause more notes to do
it anything else okay well thanks a lot
I'd like to hear from you over email or
in person what you think about all this
and you know thanks for your comments
and questions are very helpful okay